also excited about the rock and roll  hall of fame which has just released  this year's list of new members the 2022  class includes pat benatar duran duran  eminem eurythmics and  dolly parton yeah we're all excited  about that lionel richie and carly simon  also earned spots in this year's class  the musical excellence category welcomes  jimmy jam and terry lewis plus judas  priest shades of my high school there  breaking the law breaking the law that  was a song i just listened to all the  time in high  school never that's why i live  vicariously through the music dude  priest uh harry belafonte and elizabeth  cotton were named in the early influence  award category and executives alan  gruben jim e iveen and sylvia robinson  round out the group congrats to all of  the honorary graduates for jimmy and  sylvia too this is a great club  and aren't we glad dolly changed i'm so  happy i'm so happy holly's in there  really excited